Hey, Katherine.
So
we just covered a lot
of new terminology.
>> Yeah, but
I think it will help if we type back
to what we learned about
in the last course.
>> That's a good point.
So, in the last course you also
talk about how to use on screen or
describe objects.
>> Yeah we did.
We talked about how objects
like the text view contain
state inside of it as well as
methods like get text and set text.
>> That's right.
But you guys didn't cover.
The setOnClickListener method last time.
And, when this method's called, it
takes an OnClickListener as its object.
And then on a phone, when a user clicks
on a view, then Android will go and
check if there's
an OnClickListener inside of it.
>> And if there is,
then the OnClick method
of the OnClickListener will
execute with these instructions.
>> Yeah, and these can be any
instructions like popping up a toast
message, or changing the background
color of a TextView.
>> Nice.
There's a lot to remember.
But do you remember the other
way we can talk about it?
>> You're not talking
about the tongue twister?
>> Yes, yes, yes.
Let's do it, let's do it.
>> [SOUND] Okay.
>> When you click on something that
is clickable that previously set its
OnClickListener, then the OnClick method
of the OnClickListener will react quick.
So what you want to click?